okay playing Alpha Fisher
I'll stick with London it's been serving
me well
at least in the opening phase
okay we'll transpose into the sign
usually we don't start with this move
order but uh
okay this is all pretty standard
yeah it goes with A6 it's a bit
different
let's still go for this
if I can't go for the median Knight P5
I think I'll just go for this sign and
there's a similar trap of um
oh there's 27.
that still looks good
so maybe it's not as powerful
scene
I mean queen A5 is coming
actually Queen B4 also there's some
logic too
Queen B4 B5
no Queen if Queen A5
B5 Knight C6
or uh B5 Knight B6 if Knight C6 I take
take in Knight B6
so it looks like The Rook is actually
getting trapped
it's definitely not a position I've had
before but
ah there's this move so I'm not actually
traveling The Rook
I need tricks
and funny line taken Bishop C7
I'm looking for tricks
hey Queen side castling
it's kind of looks wrong though
I shouldn't be spending too much time
here
wait I've taken Queen D5
Bishop takes Knight B6 Rook T oh no Rook
d8 Bishop C7
okay I think I'm winning something
because Queen D5 now
it took a while to spot
I think there should be Southern coming
uh the 95
23 and queen D2
yeah there's some compensation for black
the Black Cat Castle gives a
night would be hanging
as plaque wants a castle queenside
let's assume the Knight moves like
Knight C5
Knight B6
foreign
maybe just F3
it's not comfortable though I have this
move
so Rook CA takes takes a three
Bishop D3
and there's Queen A4 Bishop C3 but
that's just a trade
oh there's that move which is
super annoying
trying to hold on
it's equal material now
look down a little bit of time
foreign
probably makes sense
oh there's Rook B okay rugby it's not
played
rookie I did have Queen E1
I mean G4
go on the attack
ah there's takes an F5
I could take with Queen
idea H5
X
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wait for it
yes
let's go that's how you save a
completely losing decision
I don't know if A3 was even pre-moved
so it didn't come immediately
uh good luck to my opponents
oh we have London
yeah it's as if I'm playing myself
foreign
been encountering this more recently
uh
pretty sure I can just play Queen z7
though
and queen A4
[Music]
yeah this should be fine
foreign
I can't actually win a pawn though
tick tick tick tick
okay
so I'm letting white get the disappear
but that would mean the Knight has to
remove itself from E5
wow so now if takes
uh there's Bishop C5
Queen G5
hmm
foreign
[Music]
that's kind of annoying
I'll just play this
maybe eventually A6
foreign
[Music]
like every move I have to calculate
taking
it still doesn't work
if you're rookie AIDS
because in the end of all these lines
there is Bishop B6 winning The Rook or
Bishop G5 Maybe
so now I am trying to take
oh
and check with Queen
a four is maybe coming
although F4 I take an F6 and maybe win
the pawn
realizing later if I don't know what to
do I'll play
it's a minority attack
wow F6 doesn't work
taking
make some sense
expecting Knight takes
I just want a simple position to play
but opponent doesn't
they take plant takes
Knight G6
Queen E2
I think that's reasonable
I have the C4 Square to work with
maybe
[Music]
um
I'll prepare Rook C4
oh
B5 first
foreign
[Music]
night trapped
traps my knight
foreign
you know what I want
what I really really want
let's go
I really really wanted it
wow
oh wow
about two in a row yeah that's two in a
row
oh man
I can't stop myself